[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à part le fil twitter du président ce
qu'il faut surveiller pour les états
unis en 2018 c'est notamment les forces
progressistes la société civile le bien
sûr énormément de gens des femmes
beaucoup aussi qu'ils ont décidé de
s'impliquer en politique de tenter de
faire le saut parce que l'élection de
dans notre chambre il ya beaucoup de
gens qui aident les immigrants qui le
compte les pourrait tenter de réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
donc du côté changement climatique il ya
beaucoup de gens qui s'impliquent
davantage dans la société civile des
gens qui accueille des immigrants des
gens qui luttent contre les gaz à effet
serre donc pour ce qui des changements
climatiques il ya aussi tout ce qui
anime le mouvement mitu qui s'est
transformé aux états unis en mouvement
time's up il ya le fil twitter du
président mais tout ce qui se passe
aussi un peu plus à gauche un autre de
ses grands dossiers qui va animer les
états unis en 2018 ce sont les tensions
avec les minorités bien sûr entre
minorités et jean la peau blanche
l'élection de deux notions bien sûr ça a
réveillé les nationalistes blancs ce
qu'on oublie souvent aussi c'est que ça
a choqué les afro américains
on en parle peut on en a parlé avec
charleville au cours de l'été lorsqu'il
ya eu des affrontements des événements
assez violent ça apporté énormément de
tension et de ressentiment chez les
noirs ils sont là encore il ya les
minorités aussi comme les immigrants les
latino américains les musulmans qui
continuent d'être victimes un peu qui
pourrait décider d'une manière ou d'une
autre de réagir en 2018
un autre dossier qu'il faudra surveiller
en 2018 c'est l'économie le président a
raison de le souligner ça va bien à la
bourse aux états unis c'est un
indicateur s'est peut-être pas le
meilleur pour parler de la santé
économique américaine
donc si on regarde les emplois par
exemple est ce que les promesses de
créations d'emplois du président vont se
réaliser il a fait des promesses à
certains groupes bien précis d'amérique
est notamment ceux qui travaillent dans
le secteur manufacturier
l'autre chose qu'il faudra surveiller
bien sûr ce sont tout ce qui se passe
autour de l'alena ces négociations qui
continue péniblement entre le canada les
états unis et le mexique
est-ce que ça va a chopé ce que ça sera
sur la glace ou est-ce qu'on finira par
moderniser cet accord